yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing max power really I'm only going
to play a quick game here really sick of
those time time stuff at the end so what
it's just just just be quick I mean my
opponents usually don't care the
slightest bit about the move quality so
as long it is reasonably quick so maybe
I should like reduce quality by 10% and
just increase the speed and that's more
dangerous at least for right now if
there's one of those ideas here on f3 g
2h 2 now 95 is 6 is going to be tricky
yeah Queenie - I can take G - hmm okay
isn't there some tactic here kind of
hard to believe that there shouldn't be
I can definitely do that
so come on let's play a fine
night each form is just just about holds
yeah that doesn't work and that
shouldn't work really
white resides yeah sometimes playing
quickly and just that senselessly pound
on the king is what what would work and
this time it did work
yeah I got a free reticle position a
tempo up because somehow he played c3
maybe that was a mouse slip yeah we this
is a playable thing for black you would
probably not that great taking I think
is helpful yes the engine confirms 97 oh
yeah those things you miss if you play
in sand moves all the time 97 years AG
is a is a cool one and the idea is that
this is strong SE cannot take check
already need and now f5 is winning
already yeah okay yeah II for that I
didn't see I of course they are heavy
form because of them of this idea to
take take on the two I guess no this one
actually cleaner for others Bishop h6
but the engine is brutally strong a
queen er it doesn't why just gets
completely annihilated Jim with all the
active pieces and now Knight H force
mandatory but it seems to lose as well
yeah black pieces are incredibly active
so it's not too surprising that he has
no defense to that yeah okay guys thanks
for watching